Yodas up everybody mad Luigi here bring
me some fallout 4 content so this is the
first guy that I'm gonna be making I'm
making a lot of guides but this one is
going to be about terminals and hacking
into terminals in fallout 4 if you
haven't played a previous Fallout game
this is there's gonna be a lot of stuff
to think about when you're doing this
but if you have there even still might
be some tips that you haven't heard of
since there are some tips about hacking
and stuff that even a lot of Fallout
players don't know so before I get into
the actual hacking of it I will note
that the there is a perk for hacking
it's called hacker perk it lets you
unlock higher-level terminals so you can
unlock any novice level terminal without
any points in the skill in the perk
however if you want advant advanced
expert or master terminals then you need
points in the skill in the perk of
hacking so now let's get into some
actual gameplay of hacking you'll see
all the green texts and it's all weird
and if you haven't seen the screen
before then you're probably like this is
funky so the point of hacking is to
guess the right password and you only
have four attempts to do this and you
click on a word and then it'll tell you
the likeness of how how many characters
if you got it wrong so you can see there
I did tier had one likeness so that
means one of the letters in tier is
correct I don't know which one I don't
know which placement but one of them is
correct and you saw a pile again one is
correct now you can see me do some
pretty weird things here if you go into
the weird symbol not weird they're kind
of normal symbols of the text that
aren't the words and you find chunks of
text that are you enclosed by brackets
caret or parentheses I believe it'll
highlight and if you click that that'll
either remove a dud so remove one of the
false passwords or reset all of your
attempts so if you just guess three
things and you're on your last attempt
and you press one of these uh symbol
groups and it restores your attempts
then you'll have four attempts left to
do so the point of these are to help you
because if it maybe it's a really hard
terminal or maybe you're just learning
on this but it is really easy to find
the pieces of symbols the groups of
symbols because they highlight when you
go over one of them so just take your
mouse take
your little controller and stand it over
the code and then you'll eventually find
one of the pieces and that'll help you
out this is a very very good way to help
you sort through it since there are
usually a lot of words and sometimes it
can be pretty hard
I also fall at fours version of this is
a little bit harder since in fall of
three or fall in Vegas and you got a
couple of letters whatever order they
were in that was the correct order that
it would be in however fallout 4 only
tells you that one of the letters you
said is rights or none of the letters
you said it's right or two or three are
doesn't give you any hints on order now
another thing I do want to note is while
you're hacking a terminal there is stuff
that people do to make it easier it's
you can quick save before hacking into a
terminal and then if you don't get the
terminal you can load that preview save
and just try it again or you can just
back out of the terminal and go back
into the terminal and it should have
reset and also even if you get locked
out I've only I've only experienced up
to advanced computers so far in the game
since I haven't played it too much but
if it's advanced or less or maybe even
more after you get locked out if you
wait ten seconds you can try again
that's something the game told me the
first time that I got locked out and I
was really surprised at that because
that doesn't seem like a normal thing
that some normal thing to me so that was
kind of weird so there's not too big an
issue if you don't get the lock unless
um unless it's up for more advanced
terminals such as expert and master they
do permanently lock you out I'm unsure
of that I will try and update you guys
on that and yet that is basically
everything you need to know about
terminals another note actually usually
around certain terminal areas there will
be a note or some sort of signifier that
will let you know of the password so
that if you find that note and you read
it and you know the password so you
don't need a hack it and you'll just get
into the terminal because your character
your player knows the pass or so that's
basically I think I covered everything
about terminals there's the perk a lot
of terminals are connected to safes so
you won't need to pick you won't need to
lockpick as much if you have a lot of
hacking and you're good at hacking
because a lot of the safes will open via
terminal so yeah that's basically it for
the video hope you guys have enjoyed
this guide I try to incorporate
everything I know about terminals which
I
think is everything and yeah thank you
for watching be sure to check out my
channel for more fall for content since
I'm gonna be posting a ton thank you for
watching and peace out